[Applause]
justin bieber returns to the vma stage
for the first time since 2015 with the
duet performance of stay featuring
australian rapper the kid leroy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the biebs who rocked overalls in a black
hoodie also gave a high-energy yet
emotional performance of ghosts
[Music]
[Applause]
which had the audience cheering well
after he left the stage
also spotted sharing in the audience his
wife haley bieber who watched her man
perform with the biggest smile on her
face
justin took the stage following madonna
who welcomed everyone to the show this
year he was nominated for five video
music awards including video of the year
alongside dj khaled and drake for pop
star and artist of the year
[Applause]
[Music]
e.t spoke with justin's on-stage partner
the kit leroy ahead of their performance
and he shared the best advice he's
received from justin he's always
provided me with advice i really like
we've only known each other for like
maybe close to a year now but um i look
at that dude like family and
he actually gave me some advice last
night about today so what did he say to
you it's more personal but along the
lines of just like you know protects
your energy
i think that's really great advice and
he's lived it he's experienced it you
know agreed a great degree
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]